donc on a tous rapports une approche
personnelle particulière à la cuisine
trois taxes lamente une histoire de
passion d'émotion
donc j'ai mis ma passion au service de
la gourmandise et donc je confectionne
des confitures éphémère mais avant de
vous en dire plus sur mon projet
j'aimerais partager avec vous une
conviction
j'adorais derrière les fourneaux j'adore
cuisiner mac est préférée de la maison
j'aime y mettre toutes mes émotions puis
ce n'est des petits plats à partager des
sensations proches barrette état
d'esprit dans lequel je me trouve au
moment où je suis dans la cuisine quand
je suis en colère je fais des tartes
c'est plus facile que tu as d'abandonner
ses plus légal pas douloureux au père
quand je voyais pas garde le parallèle
avec les panneaux ans après quand j'ai
demandé marge des gâteaux je met au club
la bonne humeur et la joie de vivre que
j'ai dans la petite tout ça que je ne
mange pas forcément que georges que je
partage avec les proches l effet
relaxant genre de 14,6 je pense que je
ne suis pas la seule dans la salle
d'ailleurs si vous y réfléchissez bien
vous avez up la gourmandise une boisson
vers laquelle vous vous tournez lorsque
nous était triste stressé joyeux jute
énerver un peu comme moi il est art
par exemple on a aussi ce cliché de la
jeune fille qui se fait larguer qui
serait dans son frigo levée elle était
le dernier point de place lavault
dernière grosse boîte de chocolats qui
déborde tout ça peut être aussi un
garçon donc après une fille de l'eau et
donc ce rapport de la cuisine des mots
sur ses pattes c'est pas très nouveau ça
a toujours existé qu'on soit conscient
ou pas quand on est stressé par exemple
la tendance à se tourner vers des
arguments plus sucré plus grand duché et
chips chocolat du saucisson chacun ses
goûts alors en partant de ce constat
émotionnellement aucune journée ne se
ressemble
lundi ne ressent pas mardi qui se
baladent ainsi de suite
on tentera cette se ressemblent le
fameux métro boulot dodo de gueule
spaghetti salades pizzas du jeudi à
l'ats et je perçois des clés possible de
faire autrement
quasi quotidiennement nos origines
un manque de temps je ne sais pas
cuisiner ne se reflète pas dans nos
assiettes
pas besoin quel est le point commun en
cas lagerfeld et le primat de monde bon
marché mais c'est karl lagerfeld propos
chaque année sur les podiums des
régionaux hic des collections printemps
été automne hiver différentes selon les
années selon ses aspirations
le primeur de mon marché propose chaque
mois dépôt des différences et leur gré
des saisons
au gré des récoltes ou gré de la météo
ce que je propose aujourd'hui c'est
d'appliquer ce principe donc à noah site
haute couture
les matières sont les mêmes le cueillir
la soie le satin le lourd la dentelle
pourtant les créations ne sont pas les
mêmes ça reste un bustier en dentelle
mais ce n'est pas le même que ce calcul
sur l'agglo fait reposer l'année
dernière ça reste une chemise en soie
mais ce n'est pas la même que ceux qui
posaient l'année dernière on ne
s'habille pas de la même manière en été
quand ça pour l'hiver on s'habille pas
aujourd'hui commence à billère alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on cuisine paris il
faut changer tout ça mais la nature a
bien fait l'intérêt inventé les saisons
chaque saison à chaque saison son
produit est un produit sa saison le
réseau printemps
nous partirons en automne il n'y a pas
très longtemps par mois de janvier
j'ai une grande envie de fraises les
fraises en janvier vous me direz simple
compliqué et on n'a pas vraiment le
temps maintenant de nos jours c'est de
plus en plus facile de trouver des
fraises en janvier démarrant en août du
melon en plein mois de novembre
pourquoi pas nous allons à l'encontre
des six ont encore une fois par la
monotonie juste envie de c'est plus
facile
j'ai envie de fraises je vais pas
attendre le mois de mars pour avoir des
fraises j'en viens maintenant et sont
moins bonnes gens voteront contre
j'ai testé je vous le garantis et comme
la nature et des fêtes donc après
l'heure c'est pas l'heure après l'heure
c'est plus l'heure pour les rays c'est
en mars
c'est loupé même si l'envié de manger
des cerises tomber des premières neiges
est plutôt tendance propose qu'on
s'abstienne de manger des produits hors
saison
pourquoi parce que c'est pas bon
pourquoi pas ce qu'il faut
attend autant cuisine en respectant la
saisonnalité des produits permettrait
d'abord une clean un peuple et variés
d'avoir des meilleurs produits déjà des
meilleurs goûts prenez pas en vrai le
vrai goût de la tomate
voilà manger toute l'année ne pas
profiter toute l'année
donc je prends au jeu je prône donc la
fin des fraises au mois de décembre
même si possible pourquoi ce que je vous
raconte tout c'est haddock la monotonie
culinaire qui s'installait dans nos
plats pour nos salles à manger dans nos
poches des jeunes et ça me plaît pas
trop je vous mets au défi vous dans la
salle de aussi remémoré les 24
totalement différent que vous allez
manger au cours des derniers mois pas
forcément pas du tout la même chose et
dérision pas du tout le peuple
indifférent c'est dépenser plus tard
forcément tout de suite je vous mange je
ne pense pas concernés sont nombreux à y
arriver baruti n'ont toujours par manque
de motivation ne refaisons l'ensablement
les mêmes plats et dont je suis
convaincu qu'il est possible de faire
autrement je viens donc vous dévoiler
mon programme je vous parle et donc de
moi et de la confiture je mens des
confitures les produits moi même des
profiteurs éphémère on me demande
souvent on me l'a demandé d'ailleurs que
l'on sommes invités pour cette éviction
pourquoi d'écriture vaste question
il ya plusieurs raisons à cela des
capots deux ans à l'occasion mon mariage
je cherchais une idée de cadeau pour les
invités qui change un peu des trajets
que personne ne mange que personne
n'aime mais que tout le monde offre qui
finissent toujours suivi et allège de
l'étagère des mamies huguette il reste
là pendant des mois et des années on les
oublie donc j'ai vraiment une idée
originale qui ne me correspondent
j'adore faire de la confiture ça tombe
bien je trouve ça ça et moi quelque
chose de familier on pense par sa
grand-mère sa maman à la tat huguette
encore qu'ils aient des confitures donc
je mens les pâtisseries confitures et
donc nous allons faire des confitures à
nos invités de saveurs différentes
appris que vanille me rappelle qu'à
d'elle un pour monsieur au format dame
lesdain tellement plus
laurette amendements au tour que l'état
germé dans mon esprit petit à petit
si je monte des confitures pas si ça
vient de cette préfecture c'est plutôt
pas mal ça fait un peu conte de fées
donc c'était la première raison pour
laquelle je me suis dit je vais me
lancer dans les confitures
ensuite lorsque moi je pense à la
confiture c'est sûrement la gourmandise
qui représente le mieux cette notion de
diversité culinaire
si je vous dis préfecture vous pensez
tartine beurre café des chocolats selon
vos goûts wavre profit tueur je pense
petit déjeuner déjeuner goûter dîner
pourquoi la préfecture c'est donc la
tartine avec le café c'est la pourriture
dans le yaourt nature ou le fromage
blanc au déjeuner c'est la préfecture
avec le crep la gaufre
les possibles à partir d'un seul plat
seulement dix dents sur un produit des
matières premières et variées des donc
dès qu'on fait la couverture est
multiple et pourtant nos deux de ses
utilisations la plupart du temps des
dirigeants avec beauté pas trop
peut-être l'apéro pour certains mais pas
trop le dîner de gêner tout simplement
et donc on cite une question qu'on me
pose c'est pourquoi des confitures
éphémère et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement le principe est simple ils
ont ponctuellement une à de nouvelles
saveurs de confiture seront dévoilés
après secret jusqu'à ce que je sois sûr
que sa bonne idée donc les secrets sont
dévoilés mise en vente sur le site rue
bab romarin kiwi cardamome framboises en
poche poivrons donc à l'abri comme ce
sont des confitures que j'ai déjà fait
qu'ils ont et auront droit qui en a plus
bahia n'a plus autant il ya plus de 13
après abril bay à pitre in japan refaire
pour toi parce qu'elle n'a pas donc le
stock écoulé t'as raté ta chance désolé
mais même si je la refais je repartirai
sur l'air du marbre mais je n'aurai pas
de la rhubarbe romain je ferai autre
chose pour découvrir d'autres saveurs
d'autre manière d'allier ce légume parce
que la lutte promet de légumes avec avec
d'autres saveurs pour proposer autre
chose que la plupart pour marin qui a
déjà été proposé donc cédé compétir qui
existe dans un temps limité le temps
d'une saison
ça a l'air de quand même beaucoup de
personnes c'est peut-être conviction est
devenue une entreprise qui développe
petit à petit des centaines de points a
été vendu une quinzaine de sapeurs été
dévoilée passage télé autour de la
confiture d'abricots ganic avait été
décrétée préfecture coup de coeur du
chef et aujourd'hui j'ai même l'honneur
de confectionner des petits pots pour
des futurs mariés donc qui veulent
proposer aussi de configurer leurs
invités une certaine manière la boucle
est bouclée on retourner aux origines
donc de la marque
donc on voit très bien que sortir de la
monotonie culinaire ne demandent pas
tant de temps d'efforts que sage son
petit résister et surtout hirose
avoir un petit côté aventurier et
pourquoi je mets dans ma confiture de
framboises que vous pourrez d'ailleurs
goûté tout à l'heure à l'entracte il y
aura quelques petites faveurs pour vous
pourquoi je le fais pourquoi est-ce
qu'on mexique par exemple y cuisine de
couler au chocolat qui est très bon
pourquoi est ce que mon époux mais
dépistage dans sauté de légumes au pays
de poulet la réponse à toutes ces
questions à la somme c'est juste et
pourquoi pas pourquoi ne pas oser
pourquoi si ce soir en rentrant chez
vous les cuisines et vous ferez les
fraises parce que c'est la saison
extrait avec avec un suprême de poulet
allez-y passons nous arrêtera si vous
voulez mettre la vodka dans vos
spaghetti allez-y c'est très bon vous
lirez peut-être la crème quand même
injuste de la vôtre
hélas la seule émission est aussi
parfois savoir que même si on peut avoir
plusieurs saveurs tout mélanger il va
pas quand même nos plus vous c'est mémé
dans les orties
on éviterait de mélanger le chocolat
avec eux la côte de porc et l'agneau
dans la casserole
ça peut être un peu compliqué donc après
les règles de base laissez vous aller
je prends donc une sorte ils sont super
je prends une diversité la cuisine
pourrez découvrir les goûts arrêtez de
s'ennuyer et après si vous voulez
toujours gardé la pizza du jeudi soir
fait le changer juste les ingrédients
donc je vous invite à faire ce soir
rentrez chez vous ouvrez votre rigueur
votre placard ou aller faire les courses
ils sont vides et posez-vous juste la
question promet ce que je ferais
différemment
mon steak haché ce soir et vous verrez
vous trouverez toujours une solution une
alternative une manière de réinventer ce
plat des quotidiens afin de sortir un
peu de cette monotonie